hey I wanted to talk today
about my immigration medical exam
so when I first came to Canada
I knew that I was going to have to do
a medical exam for immigration
but I didn't know when in the process
that was supposed to happen
um when you apply for permanent residency
in the application
they tell you to wait until
they tell you to go
so they sent me um
it looks like it was sent to me
like on May 20th
this year
so it was like a month after
I ended up
applying for my permanent residency
but they send you a notification with a letter
with instructions that essentially show you
and tell you what you are supposed to do
um what you're supposed to bring
and then on the website you
they also kind of tell you
what they are looking for
I had called the physician
that was approved to do it beforehand
just to kind of get more information
about the cost
when you go through the immigration
medical physical
they tell you
that this is an out of pocket cost
and that you would have to confirm that
with the labs and
positions office
that you're going to
so I will also be sharing that
cause I have receipts for all of that
I won't show you the actual receipt
but I have the numbers
um but basically when I
when I went to go do the physical
I had a lot
of medical anxiety
um I have always had medical anxiety
so when I was there
I had some pretty high blood pressure
that they were a little bit worried about
but throughout the appointment
it was going down pretty consistently
so he he felt much better about it
by the end of the
physical um
during the physical
they essentially
just ask you
a bunch of questions
about your health
your previous history
as far as like
your health
your mental health
drug use alcohol
things like that
normal questions
that you would go through
on what I would think
is any physical
um from there
they listen to your breathing
um I did have to undress
in order for them to um
to essentially examine my skin
but they don't touch any private part
of your body
um and the doctor
that I had
was very open about um
me being comfortable with him
and so he had
even offered to bring in a female assistant to
um to view
while I was being examined
um and so
I really appreciated him
being mindful of that
of course
um overall
the physical portion of the medical exam
lasted about an hour
um with all of
like the waiting
and stuff like that
they also do a urinalysis
while you're at the doctor's office
um and in total
the cost of that was $240
um for just the office visit
which again
they make you aware
that this is an out of pocket cost
and not covered by healthcare in Canada